Welcome to the new Dreamflow where you
can build, preview, and deploy your apps
all in one place, giving you the freedom
to develop however you want through
prompting our AI agent, visual
development, or interacting with the
code itself. So, let me give you a tour.
Let's start with a prompt. Let's build a
habit tracker. The first thing Dreamflow
is going to do is formulate a plan that
you can see over here on the left. On
the right, you're going to see the
execution of that plan, including each
of the tasks it's going to accomplish,
the files it's going to edit, and the
diffs that you can expand to see what
it's actually doing. Additionally,
you'll see any of the packages that it
adds, and all of the classes that it's
writing. After it writes these files,
you can click into this view generated
files and select any file you want and
see all the code that's written. When
the task is completed, you'll see that
DreamFlow checks it off. And if you have
some extra time, you can play Asteroids.
All right, let's go back and view our
progress. And let's close out these
messages right here. And you can see
that we're almost done. As it's writing
the code, it will compile it and check
for errors. And if there are any errors,
it will fix them. All right, it's done.
So now it's opening it in DreamFlow. And
beautiful. Here's our app. Now, let's
get a little accustomed to this
interface. Now up here you can see a
couple of different options. And this
left one over here when I select it will
be my widget tree. So you can see all
the widgets on your page. Next over here
we have our properties panel. Now we
don't see anything right now because we
don't have any widgets selected. So we
can't see any widgets. But this is
getting a little bit cramped right here.
So I could shrink it down. But actually
I'm just going to close this agent panel
right here. And that's this third
option. There we go. That's feeling
better. The last main section is right
here. A preview of our app. Well, it's
actually the app itself. This is the
complete running version of your app.
Okay. So, let's make some changes here.
So, the first thing I want to do is I
want to change this title right here.
Now, I could click through right here
and try to figure out where this is, but
there's an easier way to do it, and
that's to turn on inspect mode right
here. And that allows me to hover over
and select whatever widget I want to
change. So, we want this text widget
right here. And when I select that
widget, you can see all of the
properties populating over here. And you
can just go in and change them. So, I
want this to be keystone tracker. Okay,
that's great. Next, this is a little bit
too big. And you can see this style is
coming from this headline small. That is
from our theme settings that you can
edit in this second tab right here. So,
that's headline small right over here.
And I'm just going to bump that down.
Yeah, that's looking better. I've got
another app here. It's a to-do app. And
if you notice, I've got this error right
here. It's an overflow error. and I want
to fix that with our agent. So, I'm
going to toggle our agent chat right
here. And there are various ways that
you can deal with debugging issues like
this. But for this one, I'm going to go
down here and take a screenshot and add
that to the agent context right there
and say in the tab bar there's an
overflow error. Please fix. Awesome. And
that is fixed. and our agent gives us a
nice summary of the tasks that it's
taken to fix it. The next thing I want
to do is I want to connect this to a
backend service and we have native
modules for Superbase and Firebase. Of
course, you have full access to the
code. So, you could use any backend you
want, but let's use Superbase. So, let's
come over here to our Superbase module
and connect to Superbase. This will
bring you through the OOTH flow and then
set up your project in Superbase. Great.
The project is set up. Now, let's have
the agent generate the client side code.
And you can see it's added to the thread
right here, and it's planning its
execution. Now, what's great here is
that because the agent has a context of
your entire app, it sees that it's a
to-do list. So, it's creating the tables
that make sense for a to-do app. Great,
it's finished. We've got a summary of
all the tasks that it took. Now, the
last step is to deploy these schema
changes. Now what's this doing is that
it wrote all the SQL to create the
tables and the rowle security and now
it's just executing those. All right,
that's all looking good. I can see here
in Superbase that I've got my to-dos and
all the other things and the all and all
the other tables. But when I go back to
the app, I'm not seeing anything. And
that's probably because I'm not
authenticated as any user. So let's
change the entry page. So I'm just going
to tell it to make sure the off page is
the entry page. All right, great. That's
done. Great. So, we're signed in, but I
don't think this button is working right
here. So, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to turn on inspect mode right
here. And this button right here, I want
to rightclick and add it to the agent
context right here. And say this button
is always disabled. Make sure it's
working properly. All right, that's
done. So, let's test it out here. create
Dreamflow tutorial.
Beautiful. Now, so far we've used our
agent to make changes to our app. We've
selected widgets and modified their
properties in the property panel. But
there's one other way that you can
interact with your app. And that's
directly with the code. And you can see
that up here. So, if I go into code
view, you can see I have full file
system access where you can edit any
file. But it gets better because I can
go into split view right here and let's
close our agent to make a little bit
more room. And if I'm in inspect mode, I
can select whatever widget I want and
it'll bring me right there to that
widget. I can edit it. So let's just
call this task. And when I save it,
those changes will be propagated in all
of the development surfaces. Also, if I
select a widget in here, each context
will be highlighted in the preview and
in your properties. But I feel good
about this. So, I think it's time to
publish. So, I'm going to go back into
preview here and go to publish and
deploy with one click. And here's our
live project. Awesome. And here's our
deployed app. You can also deploy
straight to the App Store and Play
Store. Now, if you run out of credits
while you're building, you can go into
your settings over here and into manage
plan. Then go into view plan and choose
the option you need. And that's the new
Dreamflow. We can't wait to see what
you'll build. Share them with us on
Twitter with the handle@dreamflow
app. We can't wait to see what you'll
build.